we'll keep proceeding here we're taking
your calls at 6 1 7 8 30 40 750 and I am
told that we have another caller on the
line hello hello David this is Patrick
Phil living baja california mexico
terrific and yeah there's going to be a
delay because i'm gonna phone this
through my my router alright well thank
you for letting me know what what's your
question well i have a couple things to
talk about when it's a recommendation
I've been watching the show for about
four months I've been a member for about
three months thank you and I feel it's
somewhat unprofessional when you're
showing a video someone you don't care
about like Trump for someone to laugh in
the background off camera sort of like
I'm doing right now yeah i mean what why
is that a lack of professionalism though
well what's funny when you're on camera
and doing it with video if it seems to
be all right but it really bothers me is
like you're slippery you know yeah
anyway listen live i do an honest show
and sometimes i cannot uh suppress
laughter because i am discussing or
watching a video that is just funny and
you know i'm presenting the full me to
the audience is in the laughter is just
part of it you know and if it comes off
and professional than i do apologize
okay the other thing i want to talk
about about three weeks ago you were
talking about the phrase social liberal
fiscal conservative and you said a cat
it can't exist well I said that about
myself for many years me too I'm 77
years old so yeah that's him in a long
time I I what I did was I went to the
dictionary went to the American heritage
cars college dictionary and looked up
conservative and the third definition
was was cautious and that's what I do I
am I believe in the social welfare
helping people believe in Medicare
supported these things all my life
but I also think that we need to get as
much value for what money we throw these
problems as we can and I might my prime
example I guess would be in California
Jerry Brown he gets things for the good
need to be done but he watches the money
also yeah i mean i agree with you and I
think you know if you do an honest
analysis and say well where do we get
the most value for government spending
it actually often is social welfare
program so I I you know it's interesting
you had to go down to the third
definition of conservative to get one
that made sense to you up but you know I
I totally agree with you and that's
where i got i understand the concept of
social liberal and fiscal conservative
but very often when you actually look
and say well where do we get the best
value its food stamps over tax cuts for
the rich its infrastructure spending
over wars etc and that's where i come
down and say yeah i understand the
concept of social left fiscal right but
in practice it just often doesn't happen
and i hope that that uh make some sense
to you and I really do appreciate the
call and you know I do always apologize
for any perceived unprofessionalism that
may come from laughter on the show but
there does tend to be a lot of it
gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / tdps the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com / tdps